Hey Rick, I'm taking lunch orders. What can I get you?
I'll take a buffalo chicken sandwich with lettuce, tomato, a little bit of mayo...
...and if they don't have that, I'll just take six waters.
No problem!
What can I get you for lunch?
Would I be bad if I ordered pad thai?
Yes.
Oh okay, I'll get a Greek salad.
Got it.
One, two, three, four. Could you hold on one second, please?
Sorry to interrupt, do you want to order something for lunch?
Oh yeah, can I get a spinach wrap with tomato, avocado, corn and onions,...
...and then could you throw it in the garbage because I would never eat that?
Thank you so much.
Sure thing.
Sorry about that.
Five, six, and then seven, eight.
Boss, what would you like for lunch?
You know what, surprise me.
Okeydokey.
And for lunch, I'll get a General Tso chicken please.